so Ken we've been doing a couple of
videos where we saw how slavery has
became more and more of a political
issue as we're going through the early
as we're going through the early 1800s
and you go all the way to the compromise
of 1850 the Fugitive Slave Act it really
starts to anger especially many
definitely abolitionists who are always
and very against slavery on a moral
arguments but also a lot of the anti
slave in party forms and then we have
the election of Abraham Lincoln in if we
listen if we zoom in on this timeline so
this is from 1860 to 1870 we zoom in
there and if we really zoom in on the
early part of that decade Lincoln gets
elected in November of 1860 which seems
at least based on this timeline to start
catalyzing a whole chain reaction of
things yeah this is a time when things
happen really fast so Lincoln is elected
in November of 1860 but this is before
we have our modern election timeline
when presidents are elect a cake office
in January presidents in this time
period didn't take office until March so
there's this huge lame-duck period where
everyone's kind of wondering what's
going to happen when Lincoln actually
takes the president lame duck is either
the current president during the
election is Buchanan James became he is
a lame duck someone else has been
elected and he has to kind of watch you
know pretend to be president for five
months until the actual inauguration
right this is no president's favorite
time when everyone knows that a new
president is going to be coming in and
so their influence is waning but what's
important in this time period is that
after Lincoln is elected and as we we
talked about in the last video without a
single southern vote he wasn't even on
the ballot he wasn't even on the ballot
for most places southern states start to
think about what they're going to do so
they know that Lincoln is an
anti-slavery president they think that
having Lincoln in office is going to be
a direct challenge to the institution of
slavery so in this period of a few
months from December at the end of 1862
February
in 1861 the southern states think about
what they're going to do they send
commissioners around saying do you think
we should succeed secede yeah
probably we should secede so in this
two-month period what they call this the
secession winter seven states in the
south secede and at this point did they
think that this is an act of war by
seceding that or do they think hey no
okay we can secede if we want to yeah I
think they don't really know whether the
United States is going to act decisively
to try to keep them in the Union they're
just waiting to find out and so we get
to so at this point
Lincoln is waiting to become president
James Buchanan is the president I guess
he's not really in a position to do much
of anything when does this become an
all-out war so Lincoln actually takes
office in March of 1861 and shortly
thereafter a southern fort off the coast
of Charleston South Carolina Fort Sumter
they let him know that they're running
out of supplies so this is a federal
fort which reports to Washington DC
which is in a way sort of trapped behind
this enemy line in South Carolina a
state that has seceded so Lincoln says
all right well I'm gonna send you a ship
to resupply you and when the ship gets
to the Charleston Harbor southern forces
from South Carolina fire on this ship
and Lincoln wasn't naive he knew that
these states that now seceded for a few
months that especially South Carolina he
he knew that I mean it was going to be
viewed as him replenishing a fort on
there like from their point of view on
their territory right from their point
of view I mean you could also have just
said you know here are some hungry men
I'm getting them some food you know let
me put my boat into the harbor I'll get
them their supplies and then I'll leave
so I think it's really up to the
southerners whether they you know use
this as an opportunity to reject federal
authority and was it just food or were
arms and as a federal fort so you know
it was everything they needed to keep
the sport running okay so it seems like
on both sides people knew where this was
going that hey if war breaks out the
South Carolina's gonna say hey we don't
want this thing replenished in fact we
want to take that for it's on our from
their point of view on their territory
Lincoln's like hey I'm not gonna let
this this whole secession thing go
I want to replenish the force that I'm
probably going to need and and and then
what happens so after the southerners
fire on this Union boat
Lincoln realizes that this rebellion is
very serious and so he calls for 75,000
volunteers to come into the army and
suppress the rebellion I said this is
shortly after the right this is just
days after the April firing on Fort
Sumter so 75,000 volunteers which is
massive by any standards but the country
is a lot smaller than yesterday yeah
only about thirty there were only about
thirty million Americans at that time so
this you know the country is literally
ten times smaller than it is today
so 75,000 volunteers is a lot yeah yeah
and then what does that catalyze well
now war is serious the United States is
gathering an army and the southern
states know that this US army is going
to invade so these and from their point
of view it's an invasion from the from
Abraham Lincoln's point of view they
view it as this is a rebellion and we're
just going to quell the rebellion right
so the the southern states they think
we're our own country they've named
themselves the Confederate States of
America Lincoln doesn't accept that
they're their own country says these are
just some states that are in rebellion
as part of the United States yeah and
then and and and at that point I mean is
it all out i we've only had seven states
secede right so there are a few states
that are still sort of on the fence
after Lincoln's inauguration you know
they feel a strong cultural unity with
the United States but these are slave
states and so after Lincoln calls for
these 75,000 volunteers that kind of
pushes
over the edge sense all right this is
going to be war it's gonna be a war over
whether slavery exists we care about the
existence of slavery and so we're going
to join with the Confederates in the
Confederate States of America
join the rebellion most notable among
these is Virginia Virginia is not one of
the original states that secedes and
most of the action in the Civil War is
actually going to take place in Virginia
and Virginia's greatest general robert e
lee is then pushed to in his mind defend
virginia and become the leading general
for the Confederate States of America
geographically it's right at the border
obviously they're home to a major
military figure and they were an
economically powerful state yes
absolutely
high and so then at that point it's it's
all-out war it's all-out war and in July
of that year there's really the first
battle of the Civil War now at this
point a couple of months everyone is
just gearing up for war but the forces
of the United States and the forces of
the south finally meet in battle at what
we call the Battle of Bull Run which is
in Manassas Virginia Northern Virginia
today and you know people will really
think at this point that it's going to
be a crushing defeat for the south in
fact people don't even really know what
war is like they're stories that
civilians from nearby they packed a
picnic to come sit on the hill above
this battle and watch it sort of like we
might watch a football game now and they
were quickly disillusioned of what war
was actually like they had to run for
their lives because this was a violent
battle and it showed that it was not
going to be a quick war the south
decisively wins this battle and so from
that point forward they know it's going
to be a very long and bloody conflict
and one other interesting you know you
mentioned the first seven states to cede
then you have you know Lincoln building
up a real army then you have four more
states to see these are
some of these states feel an affinity to
the United States they are slave states
but not all the slave states left right
there are four more slave states that
stick around most important of those is
Maryland and Maryland of course is right
on the border of Washington DC DC is
sandwiched between Maryland and Virginia
right and so if Maryland leaves and
joins the rebellion then Washington DC
is in real trouble because they will be
completely surrounded by enemy territory
fascinating